[Musique] d'
accord Malcolm je t'aide
pas jamais pourquoi tu ne me l'as pas dit
quand j'étais en vie mon mari est mort nous n'avons
jamais eu de note
[Musique]
hey c'est Hannah Hannah Baker j'aimerais que ça
s'installe parce que  pour vous raconter
l'histoire de ma vie, plus précisément
pourquoi ma vie s'est terminée et si vous
écoutez cette cassette, vous êtes l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles et la vérité ne croyez pas
tout ce que vous entendez,
quoi qu'Hannah ait pensé avoir vu, elle a menti
à ce sujet  presque des goûts mais c'est une
reine du drame fou, nous venons de nous tuer pour
attirer l'attention et a des secrets mrs.  Baker
secrets cachés Ella l'a tué
peut-être que je ne saurai jamais pourquoi tu as fait ce que
tu as fait Je peux si tu comprends ce
que tu as ressenti tu ne connais pas toute l'histoire de quoi d'
autre ai-je besoin pour savoir que tu es comme
les autres  mais je ne suis pas tout le monde
est tellement gentil et ils vous poussent à
vous suicider
et tôt ou tard la vérité sortira
[Musique]